pouvait pas passer un halloween sampler
j'ai des chroniqueurs alors l'équipe de
production a donc organisé un faux
tournage d' halloween on a demandé à
certains chroniqueurs de venir pour
essayer les costumes
alors je sais pas ce que vaut ce magnéto
je préfère vous le dire que je n'ai pas
vu c'est nous et notre chance
regardez les deux ans c'est-à-dire
petite sorcière entre tous un atelier
masques et où je reviens je juge
certains trucs et tous ces bons mais la
version
[Musique]
mais pourquoi vous faites ça c'est qu'il
est
[Musique]
[ __ ] mais à 8 608 lui comme une merde
comment je vais pas deviner un truc
comme ça
c'est ce crime
on a du joker puisse connaître ça se
regarde parce que ce qu'il te plaît
c'est moi je reviens mais je demande
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous êtes trop grave
enfin on peut rien faire normalement
dans cette baraque devant sanglante et
david fantôme d'avis joker tu as des
masses je te laisse regarder je reviens
jambes pendantes en narcisse et s'en
sort donc non c'est une non ok jazz
comme ça on se doute hockey confinement
tout la même ciao
[Applaudissements]
ça va j'ai envie qu'il y voit là ils ont
fait tout ce tout s'arrange et là ils
sont faits plaisir jean